En este video quiero mostrarte cómo podemos
convertir decimales que se repiten en fracciones.
Así que digamos, vamos a empezar escribiendo
un decimal que se repite, digamos que tenemos...
el número 0.7 y aquí vamos a decir que se
repite el 7, esta barrita que se pone arriba
del 7 no es otra cosa más que decir que el 7 se repite por siempre, entonces vamos a poner,
7, 7, 7, 7, otro 7...
y así podemos continuar por el resto de la eternidad pero como quiero hacer un video más o menos corto,
pues no voy a seguir toda una eternidad, así que vamos a dejarlo expresado de esta forma.
Y el truco fantástico para resolver este
tipo de problemas, es expresar este número
como si fuera una variable, entonces a éste
vamos a llamarle, que es la variable "x",
muy bien, entonces,
¿qué es lo que vamos a hacer?
Vamos a fijarnos en qué pasa si
multiplicamos a "x" por 10.
Entonces vamos a multiplicar a 10... a "x" 10 veces, entonces fijémonos en que es lo que nos da.
Si nosotros multiplicamos un número por 10,
lo que pasa es que el punto decimal se recorre
a la derecha una posición, verdad,
entonces esto nos queda como 7.777
y como aquí se repetía una infinidad de veces el 7, pues aquí se queda como 7.77777... y así sucesivamente.
O lo que es lo mismo, expresándolo con barritas
esto es 7.7 barrita, muy bien.
Entonces, el truco aquí va a ser lo siguiente...
déjenme... déjenme reescribir estos,
pero poniéndolos en el orden que me interesa,
voy a escribir "10x"...
"10x" es igual a 7.7 barra, que es 7.7777...
y así sucesivamente...
Y ahora lo que voy a hacer es, restarle "x",
vamos a restarle "x", ok.
Y restar "x" es restar 0.7 barra o restar
0.7777 etc... muy bien.
Y ahora,  ¿por qué... por qué hice esto de restar?,
¿por qué fue que hice esto... perdón... de restar?
Fue porque yo lo que quiero es cancelar estos
7 que se repiten, mira, si nos damos cuenta,
al restar "10x" menos "x", lo que nos queda
acá al menos del lado izquierdo son "9x",
ok, pero por otro lado, aquí este 7 se cancela
con éste, éste con éste, éste con éste...
si te das cuenta, todos los 7 se cancelan
y lo único que me queda es 7 menos 0
que es 7 y lo mismo pasa de este lado verdad...
7... digamos, podemos decir que los 7 barra
se cancelan y tenemos 7 menos 0 que es 7.
Y esto está fantástico porque "x" era el
número que yo quería expresar en fracción
y ahora ya sé que 9 veces "x" es 7, entonces
si dividimos en todos lados entre 9,
lo que tengo es que "x",
mi número es 7 sobre 9, muy bien.
Y entonces ya escribí este decimal que se
repite muchas veces como una fracción.
Vamos a hacer un ejemplo más, pero vamos
a dejar esto aquí para que nos sirva de base
para ver cómo resolverlo.
Digamos que tenemos ahora el número y de
una vez le pongo su variable, "x",
digamos que es 1.2 y el 2 se repite, es decir, esto
es 1.222 y se repite una infinidad de veces.
Entonces, el mismo truco, vamos a multiplicar
por 10, multipliquemos este número por 10
y entonces, ¿qué es lo que nos queda?
el punto decimal se recorre a la derecha y
nos queda, 12.222 y así sucesivamente
o lo que es lo mismo 12.2 barra, muy bien.
Entonces, si pongo este número abajo para
restarlo, digamos, solo lo estoy copiando...
ok, ahí está copiado...
Y ahora lo restamos... lo restamos...
Vamos a restarlo y aquí nos queda, "9x",
acá se cancelan los dos barras y me queda
12 menos 1 es 11, muy bien, o acá, es lo mismo verlo acá, los dos se van cancelando y me queda 11.
Entonces, si dividimos todo entre 9, ok, si
dividimos entre 9 nos queda
que "x" es igual a 11/9 y ahí ya tenemos dos ejemplos de cómo resolver este tipo de problemas.